all right say no more say no
more yep yep 32 one Emily
y I saw Fruits Basket I saw [__] card
capter I saw Orono I saw [__] what else
is there everything is that Tokyo muu on
the bottom there that is Tokyo mimu on
the bottom yes I mean every show is um
follows girls this is everything Emily
draws this literally everything Emily
draws so there's n fuit basket K Sakura
or KAG panning stocking which is based
um [__] konosuba Tokyo Mumu and
what's the right one there uh Skip and
loafer that's that's something to add
this year yeah they love Skip and lo
Skip and loer is great uh I didn't see
it yeah genuinely I know why Emily put
ski and lo for there that show screamed
Emily it looks like it looks like Emily
Drew that doesn't it it's cute it's
Feelgood it's one of my favorite
romances that air this year as well and
it's been a long time since I've seen
characters that actually feel like
people and not anime characters um it's
just a very genuine show honestly the
one that sticks out to me is pany and
stalking I did not expect I mean I I
assume Emily's going to say like oh I
like pany and stocking because the art
style is so unique which it was and it
still is to this day but it just I don't
know does it didn't it doesn't seem like
a show that Emily would be into you know
what I mean I can I'm I'm like hang out
with Emily I wouldn't be surprised if
she put this on here uh because she saw
it was like you know knowing what type
of person Emily is and the background
that she has know it's like seeing panty
in the stocking for the first time and
just hearing the amount of [__]
swearing yeah and just how grossly uh
just how gross it is at some point she's
like oh oh my God maybe this is like
Awakening something in me I don't I
don't know why why do I why do I kind of
like why do I kind of dig this what the
hell feel like saying [__] they they
just say [__] and [__] in my anime and
it has a transformation sequence as well
like magical girls what yeah because P
stalking is just a magical magical girl
Series in Disguise it's so good yeah and
pain talking season 2 coming out soon
[__] yeah let's go I'm so pumped for
that obviously card cap to Sakura as
well uh I don't know if Emily watched
card cap to Sakura or the OG card capts
uh which I count as a different show
that is a different show yeah what
what's the difference uh because it was
dubbed for America and it kind of did
you hear about the one piece four kids
dubb controversy at all well when they
changed like like
animation it's just yeah which which
controversy we talking yeah there's a
lot okay just the just the fact that he
exists yeah I remember I remember cuz I
watched one piece uh on Cartoon Network
and I remember that the like they change
all like the weapons to like toy weapons
Sanji doesn't smoke cigarettes he eats
lollipops I remember that too it it goes
more than that they changed all of the
music to resemble more like Saturday
morning cartoons so all the original
soundtrack is gone best anime opening of
they changed characters to be hey hey
Wacky I'm going to say a pun kind of
like character uh so they basically
changed the entire Vibe and everything
about the show um and I wouldn't say
card capts was on that same
level of changes but there definitely
was a hell of a lot of changes uh I mean
they changed the names of the characters
uh I think Sakura is the same cuz it's
card cap Sakura I think her best friend
they changed her name to
Madison Madison yeah they changed her
name to Madison what her real name I
can't remember because I'm not going to
lie [__] M I'm not going to lie that
dog looks like it's fan art inserted
into that picture it does furry like Sal
it doesn't it doesn't look real it does
look like a piece of furry art it looks
like it's she been put in
there My OC with Sakura like why like
what is that is that
Madison no Madison's the blackhaired
chick yeah yeah know yeah yeah well I
forgot I forgot what his name was now I
haven't seen card character in so God
damn long I'll be I'll be honest I
remember more about card CS than card in
Japan there seems to be these show that
are more aesthetic shows and this seems
to fall into that where I see a lot of
people who like more so the aesthetic
than the actual show itself well Cod
Captain Sak was uh is written by clamp
who made some of the most like you know
visually aesthetic shows of that kind
right yeah so like everything clamp made
was just like oh my God this looks so
pretty cuz like when I ask people you
know who really like the show I'm like
why do you like it they're like I just
love the like aesthetic and they love
the the vibe of it as opposed to he it's
quite a great story yeah I I remember
the vibe of card Sak I don't remember oh
yeah her name was tomoyo tomoyo oh oh
and it became mad Madison
Madison hey Madison wait so was was that
is out of pocket so did they change all
the character names no I think Lee they
didn't change because Lee there's you
know just say is the same KIRO was his
name KIRO yeah K I guess kobos was too
long KOB baros was too long k on it was
K I think they changed they changed his
her brother's name as well so it's not
Yuko um so like
John Sakura and Clive I like how they
just kept Sakura cuz it was like Sakura
Sakura Sakura beautiful go uh C Captain
Sakura dub character names here we go
okay let's see let's see let's see what
do we got Sakura Avalon instead of
Sakura
Sharon Lee is Lee Shon oh my God okay
Caris is still car okay that's good Tomo
is Madison
Taylor Toya kinomoto is Tori Avalon okay
okay Yuko is Julian
star what the [__] okay me Lee is me Ray
what the f why what why why did that
change that makes no sense whatsoever
Ariel hiawa is Eli
moon what the [__] yeah they didn't
change Knuck his name though Ruby Moon
Leila McKenzie kah mizugi is Leila
McKenzie bro well yeah that's sheih is
Chelsea oh
my oh my God why would you do
that God back back in the day of English
localizing dubs we Wang is still Wang
Wang yeah they're like that's that's
just a banger that's a banger we Wang is
so Wang is a banger name we're not
changing is just
Maggie what the actual
[__] oh my God yeah so I'm interested I
I'm assuming she would have watched the
DU of card capts uh because that was the
thing that Ed on TV back in the day oh
my God that's so funny of course yeah n
Jo is there um went n Cafe with her it's
awwesome yeah n still been meaning to
watch so funny still been meaning to
watch that I know it's so goed and
everyone talks about how amazing it is I
just need to watch it I mean it it's
like the obviously the comedy is always
subjective so like a lot of I know a lot
of people who don't really understand
the comedy of n because they just don't
really like the kind of L random
subverting expectations kind of humor
but what makes the show so good is just
K animations just work on it it's I like
the style so aesthetically beautiful
it's so impressive and expressive and
they managed to like hold on to
C's like manga art style as well like
the manga looks exactly looks very
unique yeah I'm surprised n hasn't been
like maybe it came out too early or
maybe not enough people watched it I
think it was ahead of his time but it
was it's the perfect meme reaction show
oh yeah you know to the point where I'm
surprised I don't see more meme
reactions of just n show characters you
know totally um yeah uh or monat as well
my love story I only watched was there
only one season of that I can't
yeah I believe so um it was it was all I
guess it was it was all it was it was
all it was good that character just
looks like how Emily draws herself I
mean that's a very common theme with
Emily favorite shows like Emily wishes
kicking this no I don't do that Emily
wishes she was Torah from Fruits Basket
bro that is Emily yeah this is this this
is just hello I'm a Kutz main character
energy I the one scene I remember from
my love story is just the scene where
she I don't know she's running off for
something and then she trips over and
then she just and then they they show
her tripping over and she's just lying
flat on the ground just like dead just
like dead I was like what why did they
have to put that scene in I don't know
yeah I did think all those character
types were made up until I met Emily and
I was like wait people are actually this
clumsy and clsy yeah because I know
exactly why she put uh uh [__] kba in
as well yeah because Aqua is Emily yeah
yeah Aqua is Emily with blue hair Tokyo
Mumu I guess you know you just grow up
on that stuff it's a solo magical girl
show um and yeah uh Kya Su is just a
really [__] good show just you know
in general it is the modern like
equivalent of that first romance anime
that this new generation is going to
look back on totally and think hey what
like what would you say is the kagio
Sumer of Our Generation romance school
days school days no I'd say oh well
because like I don't know was there a
romance comedy like Kia Sumer that came
out cuz like I feel a lot of the romance
shows that we look fondly over I feel it
was Tora yeah but like I was going to
say Tora but like it's not the same Vibe
right cuz KAG summer
definitely I don't think it has to be
exactly the same VI romance in general
big romance toor because here's here's
the trajectory every like a lot of anime
fans take right uh which is you discover
anime through one of the main stream
Showdown maybe it's probably Naruto sure
back in the day and then you're like oh
wait there are things there are anime
about things that aren't people punching
each other and then there's always like
that one guy or that one friend who
recommends a romance anime for you to
watch and I feel like in this day and
age it is
kagama uh in our generation it' probably
be tororo because that one guy was
probably like don't worry there's some
actual epic action scenes on toora I
feel like it was either Toradora or Clan
ad does clad count as a romance I'm not
sure yeah totally it's just the slowest
Romance of all [__] time it's also
one of the most depressing romances of
all time as well part two part two is
just depressing cuz you're like [__]
talk to each
other uh yeah and uh yeah I mean what
else can we say about all of these
romances is the kind of romances that
Connor absolutely despises as well yeah
yeah these are all romances I would
despise I mean the only one you kind of
like is panning stalking I [__] with
panting stocking a lot yeah koruba you
like right I love koruba yeah and you
like K summer I haven't watched KAG
summer oh okay I think you'd like KAG
summer I don't think you would like k no
no why not well because KAG summer has a
lot of Comedy elements to it which I
think he might find that he can't look
past the high school element of yeah the
high school element is frustrating okay
it's the the entire like a lot of the
comedy revolves around its idea of them
being the student the student council
right I [__] hate
student like I I know Conor I'm like
he'll hear high school he like okay
maybe maybe I could look past it he'll
see student council who was like all
right I'm out I'm out out I'm out why is
the student council in in Japanese anime
have more power than the [__]
presidency they they somehow can get
[__] done because that's what Japanese
high school kids wish in their head
that's how they Envision it in their
head cuz that's all they know I don't
know just a power fantasy you know all
right but yeah uh this was very typical
of Emily good job um uh good good job em
good job Emily for you know fulfilling
your stereotypes let's go on to the next
one